president biden's
launched his tax plan we've heard about
it everyone reads about it you know
capital gains is going to go from 20 to
39 sick so corporate tax is going to go
from 21 to
28. you know top line marginal ordinary
income is going to go 39.6 and i'm not
counting the additional obamacare which
is the 3.29 or whatever the percentages
that you have to pay for what are your
thoughts about what's being proposed and
what do you think will get done and
will they be able to retroactively take
you back to one one of 2021
uh all very very good questions patrick
um
let's start with the capital gains tax
because i think that's the most
interesting one because it actually
doesn't raise revenue
even the liberal think tanks say look
this doesn't raise revenue
the government uh accounting office says
and so and yet they want to raise uh
capital gains tax and it's almost like
it's a uh you know we've got this big
call to tax the rich well
what i think what people miss is that
the rich pay all the taxes to begin with
right i mean they pay 80 of the taxes
the the taxes aren't
50 of the public doesn't pay tax hardly
at all
right and the and the other 50 is paying
all of it and most of that's being paid
by the top
10 percent so uh i think a lot of it is
is show now the the challenge with the
capital gains tax of course
there's the capital gains tax during
life which is
bad enough i mean it's you know it
affects markets and there's a question
you know
can you do that and what will the impact
be
but the capital gains tax at death is
actually pretty serious because
uh you know there's been some
calculations that if you follow biden's
tax
proposals through uh somebody with a
hundred million dollar estate
uh could easily end up with two million
dollars whose heirs end up with two
million dollars
but 98 million dollars is taken by the
government between the state tax
and uh capital gains tax so we're
talking about
a a massive shift in policy
let me say that one more time because
the audience may have not paid attention
to what you just said
so somebody who's amassed a 100 million
dollars of wealth okay
with biden's tax laws they could
potentially only transfer
upon death only 2 million of that 98 to
their errors is that what you just said
correct and 98 million would go to the
government
if if his tax laws pass if you follow it
exactly the way i mean these
calculations been run and not
not just by me um if you follow all of
his proposals through
you've got to assume that somebody with
a you know if they have 100 million
dollar state they probably have it's
probably a business right
and they probably don't have any what we
call basis for that so when they
sell if they sold that business they'd
pay
capital gains right now 100 million
dollars but they'd also
under what the plain language is
they'd also pay 45 estate tax
plus you have state income taxes right
you can't ignore state income taxes you
know when we
you know the biden talks about this
increase in corporate rates like
the federal rate is the only rate
corporations pay when that's
not that's far from the truth i mean
some states
charge uh a large portion of the taxes
so it do you mind if we do this together
i'm going to have my editors
show this so they understand i'm
tracking with you so i got 100 million
dollars i want to sell my business how
much of
that hundred million do i pay in town
and i'm in california let's just say
or new york because i see what you're
doing i'm in california i got 100
million dollar business i sell it
how much do i pay capital gains taxes
under biden's laws
so in in california just california
alone you're going to pay 13.3 percent
okay so that's 13.3 million okay
uh uh biden you're going to pay
somewhere between uh 39.6 million
and depending on if you end up having to
pay the
obamacare tax that's another three point
eight percent well you can't avoid it so
if you're living in i'm i'm paying a
three-year-old you literally
could end up paying 43.4 percent
so okay let's stay together federal tax
so at this point you have me at 56.4
million is gone
i have 43.6 million left to my name what
what else will i pay right but then
you've got a
understanding you've got a 45 you've got
okay so you have three and a half
million dollar exam so out of that
hundred million
three and a half million dollars isn't
subject to a state tax
but 96.5 million is subject to a 45
state tax so you take night
45 of 96.5 million
and add that to your number and i think
you come up with right of 198. you s
you see if uh i'm close there i think
i'm pretty close
oh so i take and a 96.5 million at
45 correct i get 43 million dollars
right add it to what you've got that
you're already paying
which is an additional 43 million so
that's 86 million
let's just say it's a 90 million bucks
right there no because because you've
got okay if you've got
you got 43 million yeah and then you've
already got
56 million yep i paid 56 oh that's right
so it's 90
i got you now so the 45 million plus the
56 million that's
that's 99 million just so you know
well 43 okay 40 40
plus 50 is 90 right that's the 99
million dollars
53 right plus five
that's eight that's 98 million dollars
so there's your 98 million and all of
that what you just said
could realistically happen to somebody
it's possible uh you know hopefully
senior minds will prevail but
um but um you know if you just look at
it on this black and white
you know hopefully you're not paying the
state tax on top of income tax you
shouldn't have to
but that's what i mean that's that's
kind of what the proposal looks like
so it uh it's pretty much a confiscation
of your assets when you die so if you
like this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye